the final Saga of the one piece story
revolves around Luffy's secret
connection to Joy boy and sun god NAA
but what if I told you that Joy boy is
not who you think or what you think what
if I told you that the NAA devil fruit
was created through human sacrifice that
its power can spread like a virus and
that by the end of the story Luffy will
have to sacrifice everything at the
altar of the sun god let's get into it
you guys know how this works if you
enjoy my one piece content and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment com for that YouTube
algorithm and check this out everybody
we are less than 10K away from 2 million
subscribers on this channel if you want
to help us get to that insane 2 million
Mark do me a huge favor and subscribe
right now finally this video will
contain One Piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned during the heartbreaking
Kuma flashback we learned about the
buccaneer race a race of extremely
strong extremely tall humans who are
nearly extinct in the modern era
Buccaneers are believed to have the
blood of giants within them which helps
to explain their enormous size and the
only known Buccaneers in the story thus
far are Bartholomew Kuma and his
deceased father clap Kuma's mother was a
normal human but Buccaneer genetics
seemed to be dominant because Kuma
inherited all of the buccaneer traits
and he is referred to as just a
Buccaneer by others not as half
Buccaneer how Kuma is perceived by
others is extremely important because
the buccaneer race are hated by the
world government and that is why this
race of people are practically EX inct
in the present day the Buccaneers are
said to have committed some sort of
unforgivable crime at some point in the
past and that is why they are actively
hunted and persecuted by the world
government in fact as soon as the truth
about Kuma's race was discovered he and
his family were enslaved by the
celestial dragons both of Kuma's parents
were brutally mistreated and eventually
killed by the world government Kuma
himself was supposed to have been hunted
down and killed for sport during the god
Valley incident but he managed to to
escape and free himself with the help of
fellow slaves including jinny and Ivanov
but how is this dark story of the
buccaneer race related to the main topic
of this video well the Buccaneers
actively believed in Sun God NAA the
warrior of Liberation and they have
passed that belief to their children for
countless Generations this might seem
like a small detail because there are
many religions in one piece so does it
really matter what One race believes it
does matter because we only learned
about NAA in chapter 108 of the manga
and the existence of this Sun God is not
common knowledge in the world of
onepiece in fact it's just the opposite
almost no one knows about naika and that
is not a coincidence it is very much
deliberate the world government has done
everything in its power to erase all
traces of sun god NAA from history and
if you want any information about this
deity you would have to look in only the
rarest and most ancient texts not only
that but when who who first heard about
naika it was from a prison guard while
he himself was imprisoned for failing to
stop the redhair pirates from stealing a
certain powerful devil fruit shortly
after this prison guard told who who
about a son God called naika a legendary
Warrior of Liberation who was red by
slaves as a savior and Liberator the
prison guard disappeared under
suspicious circumstances and was never
seen again who's who quickly realized
that all knowledge regarding NAA was
strictly forbidden and the guard was
likely killed by the world government
for even mentioning NAA to another
person who who then decided to risk his
own life to escape from prison because
he felt that he would be killed next
since he now knew the Forbidden
information about naika and the
experience of who's who is just one
example over the course of the last
eight centuries the world government has
likely killed countless people in order
to keep all information about NAA hidden
I wouldn't be surprised if they erased
entire towns and cities maybe even
entire kingdoms from history just to
make sure that no one learns about NAA I
mean just look what happened to Ohara
and lulua so yeah the fact that the
Buccaneers worship NAA in particular is
a big deal and Kuma's backstory gives us
some massive clues about the true nature
and origins of both naika and joy boy
and the Buccaneers don't only know about
NAA in like general terms they also know
specifics like the fact that he has an
all-white appearance they know the
rhythm of the drums of Liberation and
they know the dance that goes along with
it Kuma even knew about the types of
powers that sun god NAA possessed and he
actually told Bonnie about those Powers
after learning the true nature of Nika's
Powers Bonnie would eventually learn to
mimic them which is extremely
interesting and important but more on
that later all of this certainly
suggests that many generations ago the
Buccaneers had some form of direct
connection to Na and that is how they
preserved all of this secret knowledge
since we know that NAA is actually the
real name of a powerful devil fruit
formally known as the gugu noi we can
assume that the Buccaneers had a direct
connection to a former user of this
devil fruit and that is where Joy Boy
comes in at first the legend of NAA and
the Mysterious historical person known
as Joy boy were treated as separate
entities in the world of One Piece
although they did always share some
similarities like the connection to
laughter and joy but in chapter
1043 zunesha confirms that there is a
direct connection between NAA and joy
boy when the naika devil fruit awakens
within Luffy during his fight against
kaido zunesha who is a former comrade of
Joy boy from 800 years ago confirms that
he hears the drums of Liberation for the
first time since the time of Joy boy and
as Luffy awakens his so-called gear five
zunesha outright states that Joy boy has
returned so there we have it a direct
connection between the historical Joy
boy from 800 years ago the drums of
Liberation and the devil fruit that
bears the name of son God NAA this leads
us to conclude that 800 years ago Joy
boy was an important historical figure
who fought against the world government
during the void Century he was also a
former user of the honomi model naika
and he was the last person to fully
awaken the power before Luffy finally
did it again eight centuries later now
since we know that zunesha was a comrade
of Joy boy 800 years ago and that since
that time he has been wandering the
world as punishment for some crime he
committed in the past it isn't hard to
conclude that the crime committed by the
buccaneer race might have been something
similar their crime might have been the
fact that they were actually comrades of
Joy boy during the void Century just
like zunesha and that is why the world
government hates and wants to destroy
them this is something that the
Buccaneers share with the lunarians who
have also been hunted down to near
extinction by the world government since
the lunarians are believed to have lived
on top the red line before the world
Nobles took over it is quite possible
that lunarians also fought against the
world government during the void Century
along with joy boy zunesha and the
Buccaneers because of that I previously
made a video in which I argue that the
original Joy boy from 800 years ago may
actually have been a lunarian however in
one of his recent videos Ur from the
library of aara reminded us of the giant
straw hat in Pangia Castle the one that
IMU Sama keeps inside a frozen Vault
since this straw hat has no direct
connection to NE alore and yet it does
have a long Legacy with important pirate
figures and members of the Declan like
Luffy and Roger it's safe to assume that
the straw hat is somehow connected to
Joy boy and his crew and it isn't crazy
to think that the giant hat in marijua
might have belonged to the historical
Joy boy himself after all this hat has
to be important if emu went through all
that trouble of preserving it and
keeping it hidden from the world I
always kind of assumed that the hat
belonged to a really big lunarian Joy
boy since we know that King is really
tall like 20 ft tall but Arthur pointed
out that the Hat could also belong to a
Buccaneer and Kuma is even taller than
King he is over 22 feet tall not to
mention that Kuma is not even a
full-blooded Buccaneer since his mother
was human assuming that there were a lot
more Buccaneers 800 years ago the
original Joy boy could have been a
full-blooded Buccaneer and so he could
have been a lot taller than even Kuma so
far all of this makes sense Joy boy was
an important historical figure during
the void Century who fought against the
world government and he was allied with
zunesha the Buccaneers and probably the
lunarians he was also allied with the
minks the fishmen the kuki clan of wano
and Lily NE frari Joy boy was also a
user of the NAA devil fruit and since
this devil fruit awakens very rarely we
can assume that much of the lore
surrounding NAA as the warrior of
Liberation might have actually been
inspired by Joy boy using the NAA fruit
to liberate slaves and spread the drums
of Liberation throughout the world there
is only one missing piece to to this
puzzle but this one piece is critical
for the ending of the story Joy boy was
extremely confident that he would one
day return and fulfill his promise to
the people of Fishman Island he also
seemed to have a pretty good idea of
when he would return because when the
Roger Pirates got to laugh taale they
knew that they were still too early and
that Joy boy would not yet return for
some time they knew this because
whatever Joy boy left on laugh taale
provided them with that information but
if Joy boy was just a user of the naika
devil fruit then how could he possibly
know when and under what circumstances
he would return I mean yeah he would
know that someone might one day consume
the NAA devil fruit as he did but he
would have no way of knowing when that
would be let alone when someone would
actually manage to awaken it what's more
for all joy boy knew the world
government might succeed in capturing
the devil fruit in the future and
locking it away somewhere so that no one
can ever find it now you might say well
maybe while Dro boy was still alive he
heard a prophecy that told him that 800
years into the future the naika fruit
would awaken again and this would
coincide with the Awakening of Poseidon
kind of like the prophecy about the two
sovereigns that Odin and Roger heard
from the sea Kings in chapter
968 but I really hope that's not the
case because that would be such a
massive example of plot convenience Joy
boy makes promises about stuff that will
happen 800 years into the future based
on some incredibly specific magical
prophecy that he conveniently got to
hear while he was still alive I don't
know about you but I much prefer the
idea that Joy boy actively engineered
his own return he actually made plans
and took steps for making that return
possible the prophecy isn't just some
magical information that appeared out of
nowhere the prophecy exists because of
the actions that Joy boy took to ensure
that he will eventually return so this
prophecy is actually Joy boy's master
plan that he set into motion during the
void century and the SE Kings know it
because they heard about the plan itself
a long time ago but how would joy boy
engineer his own return 800 years after
his death well it's obviously connected
to the NAA devil fruit and we still
don't know how devil fruits were
originally created but we do know that
the lineage factor is involved that zone
devil fruits can be artificially
recreated thanks to the lineage factor
and that even paramia powers can be
artificially recreated within the
seraphim thanks again to Dr veega Punk's
Research into the Linea tractor I think
that the original Joy boy was somehow
able to transfer his own will into the
naika devil fruit possibly through some
form of human sacrifice meaning he
sacrificed himself in some way in order
to insert not only his lineage Factor
but also part of his very Soul into the
NAA devil fruit now it's possible that
every devil fruit was created through
some form of sacrificial ritual and
maybe all of them see secretly contained
The Souls of someone who died in order
for the fruit to be created in the first
place but since we don't have
confirmation about how devil fruits were
created we can only speculate what we do
know is that the NAA devil fruit is
special and that it appears to have an
extremely strong will even for a Zone
fruit the GTO say stated that they have
been actively trying to capture this
devil fruit for centuries but it has
always managed to evade them it's like
this devil fruit has a strong will of
its own and is intentionally evading the
world government it's as if the NAA
devil fruit isn't an inanimate object at
all but rather a living creature a
creature with a soul and a will of its
own if Joy boy somehow managed to imbue
a part of himself a part of his soul
into the Naik devil fruit that would
explain a lot not only does it explain
the naika fruit's strong will and
ability to deliberately evade capture by
the world government but it also
explains how the original Joy boy knew
for a fact that he would eventually
return and when he knew that the NAA
devil fruit would awaken once again
because he himself would ensure that the
devil fruit evades capture by the world
government until the time came for Joy
boy to return and fulfill his promise to
Fishman Island and the rest of the world
that's why the poneglyphs were created
in the first place Joy boy knew that he
would return because he himself would
make sure of it and he needed to set the
stage for that return by essentially
leaving instructions for future
Generations through the poneglyphs this
could be why Toki decided to travel so
far into the future because she was
hoping to witness the fabled return of
Joy boy and maybe this is why zunesha
says that Joy boy has returned when the
NAA devil fruit awakens within Luffy he
doesn't say oh it's the NAA devil fruit
I've seen that devil fruit before and
now I'm seeing it again but with a
different user no he literally says joy
boy has returned as if some part of the
original Joy boy is still there within
NAA and so now that the fruit has
awakened Joy boy has awakened as well
but now that we've established that the
NAA devil fruit and maybe even all devil
fruits could involve an element of human
sacrifice and now that we've established
that some part of Joy Boy Might
literally be inside the Nika devil fruit
let's talk about the real nature of
Nika's power and why its true Awakening
may be even more insane than any of us
imagined let's go back to Bonnie and her
ability to replicate the reality bending
powers of Na after learning about them
from Kuma her sudden ability to
drastically alter her body in cartoonish
ways like NAA is officially ascribed to
her own devil fruit the Toshi Toshi noi
which can alter her own age and the age
of others more specifically when she
uses a technique called Distortion
future she can age her own body in a
very interesting way she distorts the
aging process so that she doesn't just
become an older version of her normal
self but rather she becomes an older
version of herself in an alternate
speculative future so when she uses
Distortion future niika like future she
is able to age herself into what she
would look like if she herself had the
powers of Na her body suddenly gains the
properties of rubber and she gains the
ability to perform cartoonish Feats like
making her fist suddenly massive in size
and these are all abilities that are
very similar to Luffy's own devil fruit
abilities now either B fruit is one of
the most overpowered devil fruits in
history and she can literally just
imagine herself gaining any theoretical
power in the future and then manifest
that power in the present with
Distortion future or there is something
special about NAA in particular that
allowed her to mimic his unique powers
throughout the story of one piece we
have seen that Luffy has an incredible
natural gift for drawing people to him
and convincing them to support him I
wonder if this is more than just Luffy's
own natural charisma
NAA has been worshiped as a literal God
for centuries and despite the world
government doing all it can to erase all
information about him he has still
attracted followers among slaves and
other oppressed peoples so the fact that
Luffy consumed the NAA devil fruit could
be part of the reason why so many people
are attracted to him and his cause there
is something infectious about NAA about
the joy and laughter this being
represents about the rhythm of the drums
of liberation and the promise of Freedom
that comes with that Rhythm and all of
this could be foreshadowing for Nika's
true second Awakening which would expand
his power beyond just Luffy and spread
it to all of his allies as well we know
that certain devil fruit Awakenings give
the user the ability to expand the
effects of his devil fruit powers from
just his own body to his surroundings as
well essentially turning the battlefield
into his own domain expansion we've seen
that with the mochi mochi noi with theoi
and we've also seen it with NAA as Luffy
already demonstrated the ability to turn
his surroundings and even his opponents
into rubber while using gear five and
that is despite the fact that the na
devil fruit is not a paramia but what if
na has an additional Awakening whether
you want to call it gear six or
something else entirely what if Nika's
ultimate power is to spread Na's unique
abilities onto other people and and
Bonnie's ability to mimic Nika's power
was just a beginning just a
foreshadowing of what's to come what if
in the final battle Luffy will be able
to Grant naike powers to all of his
allies including the straw hats but
maybe also other overpowered characters
like Shanks dragon or Kobe what if this
is the ultimate power of both NAA and
joy boy the most ridiculous power in the
world the power to manifest not only
Luffy's own dreams into reality but also
the dreams of everyone else who is
fighting alongside him I'm sure that a
lot of people wouldn't actually want to
see this because it would feel so
overpowered and we might get the kind of
reaction that tabat the creator of Black
Clover got when he allowed his
protagonist to share his unique power
with his allies tldr many people did not
like it so if Oda really is planning to
do something like this that he would
need to include a massive drawback to
using such a power and that is where the
final part of this Theory comes into
play throughout one piece there have
been multiple instances of Luffy
overexerting himself in battle so much
so that he was said to be using up his
very life force and essentially
shortening his own lifespan some believe
that Roger did something similar
throughout his life and that is why he
eventually developed a mysterious deadly
disease some even believe that the very
same thing happened to the historical
Joy boy 800 years ago and the reason why
he lost the war against the world
government was because he over exerted
himself and contracted a disease similar
to Rogers then when he already knew that
he was dying he sacrificed his life in
order to transfer a part of himself into
the na devil fruit so could Luffy
actually be sacrificing his own life and
shortening his own lifespan by using NAA
and could the second Awakening that
allows him to share that power with
others drain him even more leading to
him having to make the ultimate
sacrifice for victory in the final
battle will Luffy get a happy ending in
the end or will he have to follow in the
footsteps of joy booy and Roger by
sacrificing his life for the greater
good and for the sake of those who come
after him the next Generation let me
know what you think down in the comments
below and if you're looking for an epic
one piece video to watch next don't
ignore this video that explains all the
different categories of devil fruit
including God fruits and Demon fruits
link on screen and down in the
description